you've been hard at work finding things
to do in Modern Warfare 2 so far and
it's time for us to round them up here's
some rapid fire discoveries made by the
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 Community
Battlefield fans are gonna raise an
eyebrow a little bit at some of the
crossover sandbox goofiness that Call of
Duty has
particularly in ground war and Invasion
and how you can Farm XP with vehicles
yeah so if you're tired of slow XP gains
and you want to unlock guns a little bit
faster but you don't want to kill people
because you're a pacifist but equip your
favorite weapon and then grab a heavy
chopper for example as your team starts
spawning you get objective points which
goes towards your weapon XP and now that
I've said that out loud they're probably
gonna patch it aren't they the community
has also discovered a broken way of
weapon farming by placing a suppression
mine on top of Tanks it's really rare
but if you can pull it off it's a
jackpot if that's really hard for you
though the best case is just to play
objectives in combat vehicles and since
we're talking about XP keep in mind that
different playlists give you better
opportunities to rack up more XP and in
this case I'm talking about Invasion
Farm the Bots feel like a God and watch
your level rank up okay back to Vehicles
you can put a trophy system on your
vehicle and it'll take out most
explosives and sometimes even kill
streaks you can carry your team from
point to point with about them actually
needing to be in a seat so if you've got
a vehicle full there's still more that
can join on the roof or hanging on the
sides like a garbage man and don't
forget there's a button now to climb on
the roof those of you that have played
the campaign will recognize this from
the Convoy Mission and speaking of
transporting your team around why not
carry your friend on the skids of a
helicopter it's real we tried it it's
imperfect but it's hilarious
for movement some Vehicles can actually
float such as apcs which is great since
water is a significant part of the
Modern Warfare 2 battle maps also don't
be afraid to use bomb drones against
small vehicles and finally players have
discovered that you can parachute into
the enemy heavy Chopper but you have to
be fast about it because it's out of
bounds short and sweet you ever use your
Tactical Sprint and run out of gas yes
the second too soon no problem just
melee run again you're welcome thank me
later quality of life settings are not
just a PC player Advantage anymore and
if anything this one goes out to you
PlayStation 5 and Xbox players who are
probably getting wrecked by skill based
matchmaking and cross play with PC
especially if you're on current gen do
yourself a favor and open up the quality
of life settings turn off or reduce the
motion blur the film grain the depth of
field and oh please in increase the
field of view slider just a little bit
all of these will help with situational
awareness in a game that's been
critiqued for being difficult to
differentiate enemies from friends this
could be a game changer for you good
news Modern Warfare 2 gives you the
option to pick skill streaks or score
streaks so if you're like me and you can
only hold W then skill streaks are what
you're going to want to pick but if you
prefer to play The Objective and rack up
a lot of points in assists or smart
counter plays and abilities you'll want
score streaks it's just a toggle in this
menu so do it Modern Warfare 2's minimap
is a little weird unlike in past games
shooting a weapon loud doesn't cause you
to show up on the mini-map normally only
when there's a UAV in the air a
suppressor only keeps you from showing
up on the Compass located here the
compass will show a red dot to indicate
where enemy players are shooting from
and the dot gets larger the closer you
are with the UAV in the air even with
the ghost work if you shoot unsuppressed
you'll show up on that minimap but with
the ghost perk and a suppressor you'll
finally be able to stay off of it
without the Goldberg you'll still show
up on the minimap when suppressed but
you'll just fade a little bit faster so
don't be surprised if enemies still find
you quickly after you shoot so let's say
you want faster ads unlike in previous
Call of Duty games you'll want to use
fewer attachments basically any kind of
weapon attachment that improves your
handling stability recoil and so on
comes at the expense of ads speed so
less can be better here believe me a
fully kitted gun might get out class by
someone using an SMG from the hip but
keep an eye out though because there are
undoubtedly some combinations you can
make where there's a solid trade-off but
in my opinion ads is definitely worth it
over any other stat and on that front
players have also found some stiff
penalties for trying to aim quickly from
tax Sprint or even from regular Sprints
so slow down bro bullet penetration is
pretty nuts in this game provided that
you use the ammo that actually adds more
penetration
most walls and cover can be shot through
which means you can dish out some deadly
combos by using a spot or nade and then
unleashing Havoc with a high capacity
mag weapon even if you don't take them
out immediately you can still have a
good amount of suppression which makes
me want to use this in larger game modes
like ground war Modern Warfare 2 has
some pretty fascinating sandbox variety
Aaron Samson and David amadi hopped into
a private server and just dished out
test after test seeing what would win
shock sticks or C4 is it possible to
hack a claymore and just how thick of a
wall can you shoot through so make sure
you stay tuned to Gamespot for that vid
because this coming next week and until
then we'll see you soon
that's pretty cool can you can you light
it off now uh probably now yeah now that
it's like
fizzled off